on reste à tours où les compagnons de
devoir ouvrir leurs portes ce week end
la ville compte 500 apprentis et jeunes
en perfectionnement chaque année des
apprentis pour la plupart très jeunes
julie posterai qui est françois que
j'allume mon frère on vous savoir ce qui
les attirer chez les compagnons
regardait et la couverture savait
également faire de l'ornementation
l'ornementation sait faire tout ce qui
est girouette
et puis qui vont bien sont les clochers
des églises ou sur les tourelles des
châteaux ce compagnon du devoir explique
au public le métier de couvreur
ici les apprentis apprennent sur la
plupart des matériaux de la tuile au
métal en passant par l'art d'oise un
savoir-faire notamment transmis par les
compagnons du devoir comme clément un
savoir faire que les jeunes développent
aussi en changeant de ville
régulièrement tu parti jeune et j'ai
vite grandi quoi j'ai 22 ans aujourd'hui
j'étais un an à l'étranger où j'ai
voyagé dans dans des villes partout en
france j'ai rencontré plein de gens
partout des entreprises différentes et
ça ça c'est au top ce plan mais comment
dire des courses en croco pdg de base
après parce que c'est un peu le but du
tour de france après sa mort est de plus
en plus en tout ce sont trente métiers
qui sont présentées lors de ces portes
ouvertes destinée essentiellement aux
jeunes en train de s'orienter
nathan lui est d'ores et déjà
intéressées pour être compagnons du
devoir boulangers ou pâtissiers
ici on peut avoir plus de temps en
entreprise ce qui peut rendre la
formation plus complète une formation
plus complète le voyage et le partage se
sont sans doute quelques-unes des clés
qui expliquent la pérennité de cette
association
chez les compagnons du devoir à tous on
a un effectif qui est relativement
constant sur ces dernières années en
forme
environ 350 jeunes tous les ans plus de
jeunes qui viennent en perfectionnement
c'est à dire que tous les ans on va
former environ 500 personnes et le taux
de réussite est net 84 % des jeunes sont
toujours dans le métier cinq ans après
leur sortie d'apprentissage et pour
aller plus loin je reçoive un symbole un
bonsoir et merci d'être ici vous est ce
qu'on appelle un prévôt cube et au
vocabulaire emprunté l ancien régime
alors comment votre association parvient
à attirer encore aujourd'hui je pense
que les valeurs que retransmettre les
compagnons sont importantes pour les
jeunes donc quand ils viennent nous
rencontrer effectivement c'est le voyage
qui les attire mais le voyage en france
et à l'international
ensuite le partage de connaissances est
quelque chose d'important pour les
jeunes et l'apprentissage d'un métier de
façon alternative est également quelque
chose qui peut la prendre
partout dans n'importe quelle cfa tout à
fait après effectivement chez les
compagnons on vient pour apprendre un
métier pour découvrir surtout le
fonctionnement des compagnons un jeune
qui vient chez nous en apprentissage
c'est qu'ils s'intéressent au tour de
france qu'il a envie de voyager et venir
chez nous en formation initiale c'est
découvrir tout ce fonctionnement alors
vous parlez du tour de france sa jeune
homme parle même d'un an à l'étranger
vous élargissez ce tour de france et un
tour de monde aujourd'hui je pense
qu'effectivement il est impératif quand
on voit tous les moyens de transport qui
nous permettent de nous déplacer il ya
encore quelques années ont traversé la
france à pied maintenant on peut voyager
très vite très loin donc la
mondialisation nous amène effectivement
nous avons rire à l'ensemble des pays
qui sont autour de nous en europe et
aussi à l'étranger puisque on rayonne
sur six continents et 60 destinations
différentes
comment vous adapter à l'évolution des
métiers vous êtes sur des métiers
traditionnels mais qui ont énormément
évolué depuis peu existé bien sûr
effectivement donc on apprend toujours
les méthodes un peu en regardant
l'histoire du métier c'est important de
savoir d'où l'on vient mais c'est
important de savoir où l'on va et les
compagnons travaillent en permanence sur
le devenir des métiers il ya des
compagnons qui sont dans les instituts
de métiers qui sont en veille sur le
devenir de ses métiers sur la
numérisation et les compagnons adapte la
formation pour que demain un jeune
puisse répondre à la demande d'une
entreprise
et puis se positionner sur le marché de
l'emploi pour réussir après dans sa vie
personnelle
est ce que vous allez me remplace par
exemple dans ce cadre là des nouvelles
formations
alors effectivement on a accueilli les
vignerons il ya encore cinq ans on a
accueilli cette année les bouchers
charcutiers donc effectivement il ya des
nouveaux métiers qui intègre les
compagnons temps qu'un métier à une
interaction avec une matière dite
naturelle et qui ce métier transforme
cette matière c'est un métier qui peut
un jour peut-être intégrer les
compagnies ça veut dire que vous ne vous
lancerez jamais dans le numérique
si tout à fait mais en fait le principe
de base c'est qu' une transformation de
matières donc que ce soit la main de
l'homme qui la transforme dans un
premier temps puis après qu'on fasse
appel à une machine tous les métiers qui
ont une interaction avec la matière
peuvent imaginer d'intégrer les
compagnies vous avez parlé du partage
qui est une valeur forte des compagnons
on a aussi parfois l'impression que
c'est un club fermé j'imagine qu'il est
je ne cause pas passer le pas
effectivement ça peut interroger et tout
le but de ces journées portes ouvertes
sont de permettre aux jeunes d'échanger
de venir nous rencontrer de rencontrer
d'autres jeunes et voir que les jeunes
qui sont chez les compagnons c'est les
mêmes jeunes qu'on croise dans la rue et
que c'est pas si fermé de ça il ya une
ouverture ou effectivement sur le monde
entier vous restez avec nous on va
regarder ce qui s'est passé dans la
région ce début de semaine
et on commence avec le mouvement de
colère des surveillants de prisons à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats elles
réclament plus de sécurité et dénonce
les agressions commis ces derniers jours
sur le personnel par des les plus
radicalisés nous ça nous touche beaucoup
pas que parce qu on a connu ça en 2016
une surveillante qui s'est fait agressé
à coups de couteau et c'est pour ça
qu'on est là pour faire hommage à nos
collègues à sait plus si fière aussi les
trois agresseurs 300 biens qui sont fait
agresser à uzerche et ça fait déjà
beaucoup en peu de gens
l'événement ce mardi à tours c'est le
transfert du service de néonatalogie et
de réanimation néonatale depuis
l'hôpital clocheville vers l'hôpital
bretonneau désormais maternité et
services de réanimation se retrouvent
dans la même structure
une très bonne nouvelle pour les parents
de bébés prématurés
après tours orléans et montargis les
policiers municipaux de gauche sont
désormais armés
neuf d'entre eux qui ont réussi les
tests vont pouvoir patrouiller avec un
357 magnum
parce qu'ils ne supportent plus
l'irrespect certains commerçants
refusent désormais de servir les clients
accros à leur téléphone portable
c'est le cas d'une boulangerie et d'une
boucherie à fleury les aubrais est-ce
que c'est dissuasif
on y arrive johan sinon je dis nous dit
franchement de poser lors de l'époque
sinon l'état attend et on termine avec
les élus berrichon qui se mobilisent
comme jamais pour faire venir des
médecins sur leur territoire le
département a décidé de recruter un
professionnel chargé d'attirer 35
médecins dans les cinq prochaines années
on n'a pas le choix on avait deux cent
dix médecins il ya dix ans on a plus que
147 aujourd'hui l'ordre des médecins dit
que si on ne bouge pas on va descendre à
100 10 vincent boulin en tant que
citoyen comment vous réagissez cette
mini polémique sur le portable dans
l'est
moi je suis assez d'accord avec la
décision de ses commerciaux avec l'outil
du portable est un très bel outil qui
nous permet de communiquer mais il a ses
limites et il est très invasif dans nos
vies au quotidien il faut savoir je
pense limiter l usage dans la vie et
dans les commerces
je suis en quelques mots vous
sensibilisez vos jeunes à ça bien sûr le
portable à table chez les compagnons est
interdite on privilégie l'échangé avec
l'autre va continuer à savoir plus sur
vous ce sera après le retour sur info
partie 2 c'est une vente insolite et
c'est une première en france
une chapelle en ruine de la fin du 19e
siècle sera proposé aux enchères lundi
prochain son propriétaire s'en sépare
avec regret parce qu'il n'a pas les
moyens de la rénover mise à prix cinq
mille euros
les murs vont tomber et vont surtout
abîmé ce qui peut rester de récupérable
et de nobles en particulier l'hôtel donc
l'idée c'est de vendre la totalité avec
la perspective pour l'acheteur n'ont pas
la perspective l'obligation pour
l'acheteur de la reconstruire c'est à
dire que le patrimoine à ce moment là
est totalement sauvé puisqu'il s'agit de
rebâtir une rune elle n'aura pas survécu
à ses blessures cindy la fillette de
bourges de 6 ans torturé par ses parents
est décédée au chu de tours
arrêté à toulouse la mère de l'enfant et
son compagnon ont été placés en
détention
il encourt la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
le chef d'accusation on va effectivement
évolué le faire était ouverte pour
l'instant pour des actes de torture et
de barbarie commis de manière habituelle
sur un mineur maintenant ce sont des
actes de torture et barbarie entend
traîner la mecque et on termine ce
samedi avec la venue hier à orléans de
céline pina cet ancien élu socialiste a
fondé en 2016 le mouvement laïque vivre
la république
en réaction aux attentats de charlie
aujourd'hui on affronte un totalitarisme
une violence une violence qui est
politico religieuse qui est l'islamisme
qui met le feu au monde partout c'est à
dire quelles que soient les nations quel
que soit même leur modèle étatique qui
quelle que soit la façon dont vous vous
positionnez viens tu es sur votre sol
vos compatriotes et qu'à un moment donné
il faut pas être naïf face à ça vincent
vous là on connaît les compagnons
bâtisseurs de cathédrales et je
construis nombre d'édifices religieux
qu'est ce que ça vous fait de voir
qu'une partie de ce patrimoine religieux
par en ruine comme ça que j'appelle
effectivement c'est une histoire qui
passe après je crois comprendre que
cette chapelle cherche un repreneur donc
j'espère qu'elle trouvera quelqu'un et
puis que cette personne n'hésite pas à
appeler les compagnons pour accompagner
dans le projet merci à vous d'avoir été
présent je précise que ceux qui auraient
raté vos journées portes ouvertes les
bains une peuvent se rendre sur le site
internet pour s'inscrire aux formations